there you go there's your circle right
now
watch out for this this is part of why
i'm asking you to draw it okay and which
you kind of got cheated a little bit
because you thought oh there's a diagram
there i don't need to worry about it
okay
put on your diagram all of the
information that you need so you have
some angles
a measurement here okay
now
if you didn't think carefully about this
your first error was just in
interpreting the diagram right the area
that you had to work out was this shaded
area yes
like so okay a lot of people worked out
the rest of the area that wasn't shaded
because we didn't interpret it correctly
right and actually drawing it going
through the process of drawing it helps
you work out okay which bits are
important to me
okay so the first thing you can do is we
can work out the average circle right
it's not 2 pi r or q pi r what's the
area of a circle
pi squared thank you very much and how
do you remember that it's pi r squared
and not the other one squared
he's on the right track you can have map
you can finish ali's thought yeah
because like the area of something is in
squared
yeah very good okay so we say like
centimeter squared or meter squared or
whatever okay so that's how you can
remember right so you can work that out
and that's where the first male went two
marks right so you had to input into
here that the radius of this circle is
five five right
okay so you can know it's five because
you've got this measurement here and the
radius is from the circumference to the
center and the center is always o okay
so so far so good you can then get your
calculator out and i think you get 78.54
something okay something like that
actually i might just um if you've got
your calculator there you can double
check and verify this answer but that
was the first mark okay so a lot of
people only knew how to work out the
area of the circle and that was okay
that gave you one mark out of two okay
yeah five four
two decimal places
okay so there's your first step
now we just want this little share okay
and if you might recall this part of it
like a pizza slice right it's called a
sector right so we just want the sector
how much of the circle
is shaded is part of that sector
so you got 60 degrees right 60 degrees
here
you need to remember
what's what's the whole circle what's
all the way and it's 360 degrees right
so i might put that in another color
360 degrees okay so out of those 360
degrees we've got 60 of them okay 60
degrees out of 360. so it gives you this
fraction right now you know it's
division because like look i'm trying to
divide this circle up into parts and
this is the part that i'm interested in
okay
you can check in your calculator or you
may even be able to recognize that
that's one out of six okay so you want a
sixth of the circle a sixth of this area
okay so the way i would have written it
is to say therefore the shaded area
is equal to here's where the second mark
came in a sixth times
this whole area that we worked out
before which is 13.09
centimeters squared because you went to
two decimal places
okay